In the Fed
investors trust.
even as its campaign
to raise interest rates
causes turmoil in the
stock, bond, currency
and commodity markets
and increases the odds of
a global recession.
Bloomberg polled a group of
professional and retail investors,
asking them
which central bank will succeed
in cooling inflation and getting the cost
of living under control.
The US won handedly.
That may be because
the rest of the world
faces additional pressures.
For the UK and Europe,
it's an energy shortage
sparked by war in Ukraine,
while China is still pursuing
its Covid Zero policy.
In other words,
the US is the cleanest dirty shirt
in the global laundry basket.
So it follows that
survey respondents
also overwhelmingly picked
the US economy
as the relative winner,
seen emerging from
the global turmoil first,
along with
U.S. stocks and bonds.
Now, looking ahead,
one unspoken downside risk
in a recovery
is a potential widening
in inequality.
The stock market would rally,
boosting the portfolios
of the wealthy
while stagnating pay
and high rents
would squeeze
lower-income households.